aliens amelia earhart and venomous jizz
american horror story's first episode of
death valley starts off with a bang so
big everyone gets pregnant it means all
four of us are pregnant in this video
we'll be taking a deep dive into episode
7 of double features theories on where
it could be headed and some easter eggs
along the way we don't waste any time
here so make sure to like and subscribe
because here we go welcome to
albuquerque new mexico 1954 where we're
about to see the weirdest thing happen
to this town since a high school
chemistry teacher sold meth god damn
right check out our first image of a
capitol records record which is pretty
interesting since the final shot of red
tide contains the capitol records
building here we get our first glimpse
of maria wykoff a stay-at-home mom who
if you've seen the previews looks like
she's going to be the alien's point
person when it comes to talking with the
government her son timothy is outside as
a bunch of dust devils form like part 1
red tide a part 2 has been given these
additional fake radio broadcasts which
you can access on the fx youtube channel
i'll leave a link to it in the
description if you're interested here we
learned that the area has been plagued
with dust storms as of late which may or
may not be the result of ufos the house
trembles the clock turns back and the
lights flicker as the alien presence
seems to take over the body of timothy
who tells his mother not to be afraid
while we later see maria exploding heads
as she's taken over by the alien
presence i think these aliens are more
or less good later in the episode we'll
hear president ike eisenhower ask why
they are here we get a hint at what this
could be in this season 10 preview
trailer which released a few months ago
time is running out so both are people
we need to create something better
part human
part us so it looks like the aliens and
humans have to team up together and with
all this talk of joining together to
create something better we can start to
see how these pregnancies fit into
everything in the radial broadcast
there's also mention of fertility rates
on the rise with reported fertility
rates on the rise in various regions so
maria's poor husband comes home and has
his head exploded and maria's eyes turn
white we've seen black eyes in ahs
before but correct me if i'm wrong i
think this is the first time we've seen
these white ones we also get a
completely new intro credit sequence it
doesn't give away too many clues but
note the repeated use of what appears to
be octopus tentacles ufos time elapsing
and babies with alien heads i'd hate to
give birth to that we move on over to
palm springs california where 34th
president of the united states plays
golf with some other officials fun fact
eisenhower had a putting green put on
the white house grounds something is on
his mind which his colleagues wonder
could be korea or mccarthy both big
issues eisenhower would have to deal
with at this time but eisenhower whose
nickname was ike is interrupted by
urgent news something was shot down by
the air force entering u.s airspace we
get our first look at sarah paulson as
mammy eisenhower ike's wife he lies to
her saying he's going to an air force
base to get help with a chipped tooth
but mammy sees past this we both know
not all of your secrets have to do with
national security i thought this was a
really interesting line i don't know
what secret ike could be hiding based on
history but expect this to come into
play later on she also says ike can't
lie to save his life so we'll probably
be seeing him have to lie to save his
life in upcoming episodes ike's military
convoy heads into the desert where we
catch a glimpse of the ufo wreckage the
president remarks on the recovered alien
body that it quote looks like a child
but perhaps the weirdest mystery is the
sudden appearance of amelia earhart
portrayed by lily rabe you may recall
that emilia was the first person across
the atlantic solo by plane she
disappeared in 1937 after she and her
navigator fred who is also mentioned by
name went missing around howland island
in the pacific she has mysteriously
reappeared with these strange markings
on her back almost looking like crop
circles she tells ike that all she
remembers is her rdf or radio direction
finder stopped working her dials went
spinning similar to maria's clock and
that everything turned white 17 years
have now passed since she went missing
and emilia is uneasy she talks about how
blood was taken from her and that things
were put inside her this is all the more
troubling when we find out she is two
months pregnant keep in mind that if
emilia does give birth to some alien
baby they'd be about 67 years old in
present day that's something i'm going
to keep in the back of my mind if this
child ends up being a character we
already know from the ahs universe the
alien recovered from the wreckage is
dissected we see a film crew documenting
it which is a nod to the alleged roswell
autopsy footage of the late 1940s
according to the doctor the alien has no
internal organs and inside emerges some
jelly type creature which sucks onto his
face his colleague tries to help but the
entity breaks off into another one now
is this thing a part of the alien or was
it some sort of invasive creature a
parasite could this thing be what is
causing the aliens to seek help from
humanity and now that it's on earth time
will be running out for us as well
suddenly the doctor's head explodes and
ike is confronted with a levitating
maria he believes they can come to some
sort of agreement but her last line is a
bit ominous mr president
it is you who will listen to us
fast forward to what we can only assume
is present day they never actually tell
us where we're introduced to four of the
most unlikable entitled pompous [ __ ]
you'll ever meet seriously i would have
enjoyed this second half a lot more if i
actually cared about these characters
instead this scene basically shows how
they all went to ivy league schools cal
here treats the waitress so
condescendingly and within the first
minute i just hated them all regardless
there are a few things in this scene
that offer clues as to what's going on
and might be important later on first
take a look at these name cards as if
they are some confidential u.s military
dossiers considering they get abducted
later in the episode i think they'll be
having a chat with the military later on
kendall's father has cancer and she is
studying to become a doctor jaime seems
to suffer from seminal plasma
hypersensitivity making her new boy toys
jizz feel like acid and finally kendall
has fallen in love with a guy from
school who is a luddite a person who is
opposed to new forms of technology this
prompts her to convince her and her
friends to leave their phones before
they go camping great idea for all these
kids who went to ivy league schools to
not have a phone in case of an emergency
while on their trip the crew is met with
some strange occurrences the pawn that
was there one day is now seemingly
missing and they come across a field of
dead bovine cut precisely in two with no
signs of blood anywhere oh and one even
blinks and moves so they decide to get
the hell out of dodge but while on the
road in the middle of the night their
car loses all power and a bright white
light envelops them strange tentacles
emerge which knock out the occupants we
aren't sure how much time has passed
when the passengers come too but they
wake up in different seats in the car
jaime doesn't even wake up in the car at
all they find her a bit down the road
and i wonder if there's a reason for
that presumably the next day all our
characters start feeling nauseous
kendall calls her bow and it was pretty
funny to see them using hard-wired
phones because they're both supposed to
be luddites and the purpose of this call
is pretty dumb she just wants permission
from him to google alien abduction in
lost time so jaime and kendall decide to
get pregnancy tests since both are
feeling ill jaime hasn't slept with
anyone and kendall is on the pill
there's also a hint here that jaime may
have had an abortion or miscarriage
because she tells kendall she hasn't
felt this way since that time when she
was 19. this is then followed by an
absolute treat of a convo between cal
and troy about guardia a parasite that
can be acquired by eating one's ass i
think what the writers were trying to
get at here is that some sort of
parasite is in their bodies this
parasite is likely their alien babies
not exactly sure how this is gonna work
for the guys kendall ends up reading an
article about barney and bette hill who
were allegedly abducted and lost time
similar to what she and her friends went
through barney and bet were the
inspiration for kit and alma walker's
characters in season 2 asylum who were
also abducted by aliens so the boys end
up coming over and all their pregnancy
tests conclude they are pregnant in past
preview footage we've seen this shot of
something growing in one of the boys
bellies also stay tuned for my episode 8
preview breakdown where i'll go over
what might be in store as well as
footage that indicates we'll see what
happened to them while they were
abducted so that's it for this first
episode of death valley i am super
curious what you guys thought of it
considering the odd nature of this
season do you have any theories on how
or if this will connect to red tide my
money is on the chemist thanks for
watching everyone make sure to like and
subscribe and for more bad takes you can
follow me on twitter and instagram at
thingstoryt until next time remember
daddy loves you very much
you